in case you're wondering who's really in
charge more than a hundred corpton
corporate chieftains held a meeting the
other day to discuss how to pressure
states to allow more voter fraud by not
requiring
id when people vote working fred hume is
our senior political analyst here on fox
he joins us to discuss
but this is a little uh have you ever
seen anything like this in all the years
of covering politics where
businesses openly weigh in on something
that's not directly related to their
core business and demand that it gets
done no i have not seen anything that i
could
compare to this and i would say that
it's it's something new
normally i think corporate corporations
involve themselves in
in politics when there's a measure
directly affecting them as you suggest
yes or when they want to support
candidates with donations
that they think will leave them alone or
help them or whatever it is that they
want
to stealthy about it though well yeah
it's and i think it's in them
and as they look at i'm sure it's they
think it's self-defense they don't want
to get regulated they don't want to get
taxed they don't want to get have a bill
that goes against them favors their
competitor or whatever
this is something a little different but
i think it's maybe self-defense in a
different way i think
i think right now a lot of american
corporate leaders are terrified of the
american left
and now that the biden administration is
in and they see the drift that
the direction it's taking which is
basically to try to enact the left's
you know main points of the left's
agenda they want to try to get in good
with them
so on this issue um
thinking that they're going to get
protested by black lives matter and who
knows
who else and under pressure from the
democratic party
particularly the person of mark elias
that's that lawyer who's been so active
in electoral matters for them
and was a was a factor in the whole
russia collusion
scam uh story then i
i think they're they're all afraid of
him and afraid of it and afraid of the
american left so they're doing what
they're doing
and i think they think they're
protecting themselves i don't think they
anticipated that the backlash against
this would be so great though
maybe they should be a little more
afraid of normal people it just seems
like
a little bit disproportionate here you
have all three branches
the two elected branches of government
controlled by one party
and the entire american business
community on the same side there's no
balance
no i agree with that and but the worst
thing about this it seems to me is that
they're basically
lying themselves with a lie the lie
being
laws like the one in georgia there are
others are
akin to jim crow that they're designed
to suppress the vote now
look there are things in the georgia law
that might make it in some ways
mildly more difficult to vote but there
are lots of things in the georgia law
that'll make it easier
to vote no that's right so they're lying
about it they're lying
britt hume thank you good one